going out and talking to random voters
is a really great thing to do during
elections actually an MSNBC did that
yesterday and hilariously ran into a
voter who said it is your coverage of
Bernie Sanders MSNBC's coverage of
Bernie Sanders that made her decide to
vote for Bernie Sanders this is super
interesting re Melbourne was in
Manchester New Hampshire yesterday the
day of the primary goes up to a voter
she says it was you that made me vote
for Bernie let's take a look at the
video what about over here who did you
vote for I voted for Bernie although
there are a number of candidates that I
really like and so I felt like I when I
finished voting I was still undecided
including Elizabeth including Michael
Bennett now that's sort of a paradox to
decide and then feel undecided so you're
a complex person yes but I want to say
the reason I went for Bernie is because
of MSNBC and go on I think it is
completely cynical to say that he's lost
50% of his vote from the last time when
there were two candidates now there are
multiple wonderful candidates who would
be great presidents and people that we
could I think that we can unify and get
behind but the the kind of the stop
Bernie citizen cynicism that I heard
from a number of people i watch NBC
MSNBC constantly so I heard that from a
number of commentators and so that just
made me angry enough I said okay
Bernie's got my vote this is such an
interesting point what you're saying is
and we take criticism because we're
journalists right we ought to be open
minded you're saying that hearing from
people whether it's gas contributors the
conversations you've heard that you felt
were draw designed to tear down
senator Sanders or scored on quote stop
him actually endeared him to you
absolutely now you'll notice how Arie
Melbourne slips in you're saying you've
heard from guests and contributors these
things
well what about hosts our email burst
sort of slipping in you're not talking
about MSNBC host obviously you're
talking about guests who are not
affiliated with us
you're talking about contributors who of
course are actually affiliated with
MSNBC but in reality it's also been the
hosts on MSNBC now the word cynicism was
mentioned by the voter cynicism is
defined as an inclination to believe
that people are motivated purely by
self-interest skepticism sometimes has
overlap with cynicism what's interesting
about this is that on the one hand one
of the biggest contributors to the
Republican National Committee has been
the parent company of MSNBC Comcast's
the big cable and internet company
provider check out some of these
donations from last year 45,000 bucks to
the RNC another 45,000 bucks to the RNC
15,000 bucks to the RNC and what you
have to understand is this it might seem
like there's a contradiction here
how can MSNBC be both quote leftist
editorially in their content and be
financially supporting the reelection of
Donald Trump there's actually a lot of
cynicism that is required here in order
to understand this first of all remember
that a lot of these big corporations are
donating to both sides because they want
to be able to curry favor with whoever
it is that is ultimately going to be in
office and the truth is that on a lot of
issues including regulatory issues with
media you've got similarities between
Republicans and Democrats on net
neutrality you've seen a significant
division between Democrats and
Republicans but on a lot of other issues
that impact the day-to-day operation of
these big media conglomerates
Republicans and Democrats are both
willing to help let's put it that way
the second thing to understand is that
MSNBC is not progressive it's an
establishment Democratic editorial
perspective shrouded in veiling I guess
throughout veiling I guess we would say
a big corporate priorities that are very
similar when you look at Fox's News
Corporation parent company and MSNBC's
Comcast they are liberal center-left
really editorially as a business
decision but a lot of their priorities
are very
very similar to any other media
conglomerate now number three Trump
being president is clearly good for
MSNBC's ratings I've admitted it's good
for our show as well I've not hidden
from you that our show has had some of
the most explosive growth in our history
under Donald Trump's presidency I don't
want the guy reelected I don't plan to
vote for him I want what's best for the
country but I've admitted that because
it is part of the interesting thing that
has been taking place in this country
over the last several years but if it
has to be a Democrat MSNBC wants it to
be a centrist establishment Democrat now
as far as the voters point she's right
some of the analyses on MSNBC have been
horrible Chuck Todd talking about Bernie
supporters as Brownshirts absolutely
crazy
comparing Ross support for Bernie in
2016 when there were two serious
candidates with support for Bernie in
2020 when there are five at least
serious candidates it's not just cynical
it's dishonest it's deceptive and kudos
to our email BER I've always seen Ari as
a pretty good faith actor he seems
genuinely wanting to know how the world
is rather than to sort of push a
particular worldview
he seemed genuinely interested in
learning more it might have been more
interesting if the person doing the
interviews from for MSNBC had been more
caught off guard in some way or reacted
in some way but it was Ari Melbourne
doing the interviews and he seemed
genuinely interested at hearing what
this voter had to say I'm curious
whether other folks have experienced the
similar push where the coverage of a
particular candidate by a particular
Network has pushed them towards or away
candidates let me know I want to
encourage everybody in my audience to go
subscribe to a YouTube channel we're
partnering with it's called
up flip they release new videos every
week in every video you meet a different
entrepreneur and get an in-depth look at
how their business works and how they
became successful it's great if you like
shows like shark tank if you own your
own business or you're thinking of
starting one the up flip YouTube channel
really does offer a wealth of knowledge
and inspiration as an entrepreneur
myself and a business owner I've really
been enjoying hearing
all of the different stories of the
people that they interview but it's
really fascinating content even if you
don't own your own business to go check
out the up flip youtube channel they're
friends of the David Pakman show I'd
love it if you would support them by
subscribing to their channel you can
find the up flip YouTube channel by
going to david pakman.com slash up flip
if you're watching this on youtube i've
put the link right underneath this video